This video is brought to you by paradox interactive.
What's up wisecrack Jared,
here to talk about the show with the best fans on the internet, Rick and Morty.
Now the most recent episode is one of our favorite of the seasons so far.
I mean, it's good.
Wet eggs. I told you not to look at that egg. It was too wet and well, uh,
you know, honestly, I'm proud of us for not, but what we found.
The most interesting about this episode is the basic question. It poses.
How much should nature define us?
Welcome to this wisecrack quick take on Rick and Morty season four,
episode seven from Mauritius and de.
Spoilers ahead.
But before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor paradox interactive. Right now they're addictive games.
Dolores is available for free on steam in this four X strategy game.
You get to customize the universe. You pick an empire name, your alien race,
and explore space. As you progress,
to be able to colonize and take over the entire universe,
you can choose what matters the most to your native empire.
By focusing on serving other solar systems,
growing your own galaxies government,
or by designing new ships and buildings for colonies. The game is so detailed.
It gives you the ability to customize everything down to the names of the
individual characters.
You can micromanage every aspect of your growing civilization from monitoring
trade and resources to select government leaders.
While also focusing on the big stuff like growing your battleships or colonizing
other planets this week, the game is celebrating its fourth anniversary,
which means you can play for free right now when you click the link in the
description. And now back to the show.
So the basic premise of primordial is this there's a parasitic face hugging
alien species that exerts total control of their host.
And as a lifespan of about 30 minutes after depositing, an egg said,
host explodes killing itself. And the proud parasite mom.
Suck on a face and die.
But some are using a foolproof oral defense mechanism, escapes, enslavement,
and convinces the parasites to forgo the reproductive urges, to live a longer,
more fulfilling life. As a result,
the parasites are able to quickly build a sprawling society with media matching
skyscrapers and Pearl harbors. And then of course,
Rick close it all up minus the twin skyscrapers of course.
Totally would have been cheap. Yeah, real low-hanging fruit.
We're better than that.
Also Jerry has bees.
I think one of the most interesting elements of this episode lies in this small
gag parasite, Rick Glorioso,
two brands against the progressive agenda of living longer. Now at first,
this seems like a quick jab at people like Alex Jones.
Did I at least sell out and sell fight amens or something?
Basic concept is mirrored everywhere in the episode,
that is if something is natural, does that make it right?
Face hugger Rick's argument for the murder suicide of host and parasite is based
on quote unquote science.
Here's a scientific fact.
I'm not allowed to say our hosts are biologically designed to
incubate our eggs. If that triggers you. Of course, this is.
Not actually science. It's the mention of science in a logical fallacy,
the appeal to nature fallacy. That is the idea that if something is natural,
it is inherently good desirable or even inevitable.
This kind of fallacy pops up everywhere in the debate about same-sex marriage.
Many people would argue that homosexuality was unnatural and therefore immoral.
Then again, getting mauled by a tiger is perfectly natural,
but that doesn't mean it's good. This is the appeal to nature fallacy inaction.
Others would point to the fact correctly that homosexuality is natural among
many of our closest animal relatives,
which again is still a logical fallacy since dictating where you can or can't
stick your genitals based on what does or doesn't happen in nature is a logical
fallacy. This fallacy also pops up around the idea that might is right.
The idea that people are justified to rule by strength alone,
that claim usually gets backed by citing Darwinism,
whatever primates do or don't do in the wild or our evolutionary history of
humans being.
Pretty much every time you hear about monkeys primates or our caveman ancestors,
you should stop listening to that person except that's a fallacy fallacy
dismissing a conclusion outright because it's logic was flawed. Anyway,
everyone shut up about monkeys already.
Parasite Rick's argument is exactly this kind of appeal to nature.
He says we should deposit our eggs because the host can biologically sustain
them. You also has a poster on his wall that displays a kind of might is right.
Logic reading that glories, those are Supreme and hosts are subservient,
which echoes plenty of bad appeals to nature found in places like social
Darwinism.
The progress of summer on the other hand is about moving past biology,
determining one's future.
Get the hell out of here and be whatever the we want.
That's evolution that's progress, but there's.
More subtle critique going on here important to this episode and life is that
people when appealing to nature often set up an arbitrary divide between good
nature and bad nature.
Since we were in eggs. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you respect like the biological institutions now.
Arguing that same-sex marriage is bad because it's unnatural.
Usually have no problem watching YouTube for eight hours a day,
getting blood transfusions or being temperature regulated by the liquid remains
of dinosaurs. Similarly parasite,
Rick has no problem enjoying the unnatural spoils of civilization or non
reproductive.
Arguably incestual face sucking while railing against the repression of
biological processes.
How come you haven't laid an egg inside this old man? Yeah,
because I do what I want. Similarly.
One could respect nature while despising parts of it that seem icky or just
dangerous like snakes,
which have historically been labeled in some cultures as evil incarnate.
And of course there's parasites, which to my knowledge,
don't really have too many positive representations in the media.
It's pretty much a default to think of them as mindless.
Hugging parasites.
I don't think their society's going to be that hard to navigate an evil.
I'm sorry.
We thought you were evil that had a giant tower that Blair
Glorioso is. I know. Should, should we help?
Here's where the episode gets really interesting because this looking down on
our face huggers is in a weird way. A mirror image of parasite, Rick normal,
Rick views, parasites as lowly,
a lesser form of life as Rick and Morty commit mass murder.
They note how good it feels to cause mayhem without guilt.
It feels kind of good when there's no guilt, huh? It's like in star Wars,
just like in star Wars.
Comparing it to popping bubble wrap, not destroying an advanced civilization.
Oh my God. This is so much fun. I don't want to stop popping. Bubble wrap.
Idea is constantly undercut as the show likens,
Rick and Morty's violence to American tragedies.
You did a nine 11 almost did a nine 11. We went with a Pearl Harbor.
We're pretty classy. Why were either of those and option 40 even comments?
I should have been a better species.
Going might is right.
Justification for destroying their world before becoming horrified by his
actions.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Not all that different than parasite.
Rick's justification for enslaving host species humans,
killing parasites is just some old fashioned natural pest control.
Even if by some unnatural means.
There's also just a really interesting question here that I love.
There's a basic hypothetical.
Is it fair to call a species evil for just reproducing as their nature dictates
what would happen if he encountered an intelligent alien that could only survive
by living parasitically off another Centene Dalian is there even a line in the
sand? We can draw as a species that lives off eating other species,
just some food for thought. And before you go,
I want to give one final shout out to paradox interactive and their strategy
games, Dolores create and customize an empire to take over the universe,
research other solar systems and foster your Empire's economy.
Right now you can play for free by clicking the link in the description.
Big shout out to our patrons for supporting us.
And we'll see you next time guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].